abone ol
[Müzik]
e
herkese merhaba
Bundan yıllar yıllar önce bir dernek
kurulu dünyada taramacı bitmeyen ve
gençlerle Çiftlik sahibi Toprak sahibi
çiftçileri bir araya getiren patatesini
bir dernek kuruldu ve Türkiye'de buğday
Derneği ile çalışmaya başladı ve bende
bu dernekle birlikte onlara başvurarak
Yıllar yıllar önce Bulgaristan'da Sofya
bir köyüne gittim Bir çiftlikte
çalışmaya bir hafta çalıştıktan sonra
oradan kazandım çok cüzi bir parayla 2-3
günde bölgeyi gezme fırsatım oldu fakat
daha büyük bir fırsat oldu benim için
orada uykuya isminde Norveçli bir
arkadaşım oldu uyku ile birlikte iki üç
gün onunla birlikte gezdikten Sonra bir
sonraki yaz onun ülkesinde buluşmak
üzere ayrıldık ve gerçekten de bütün bir
yıl boyunca iletişim bu bitti Bir sene
sonra bir sonraki yaz beni bütün
masraflarımı karşılayan bir davet
mektubuyla ailesinin evine davet etti
Ben bizim aldım ve arkada görmüş
olduğunuz norveç'teki Rain kasabasına
doğru yola çıktım Uçağa bindim uçaktan
indim otobüse bindim en son bir
gemiye bindim feribota bindim ve Nihayet
kasabaya vardım Günler geceler birbirine
karıştı Çünkü özellikle Kuzey
ülkelerinde çok gezerken yaz aylarında
hava çok geç kararıyor ve çok erken
aydınlanıyor iki üç gün uyuyamadım ve
bir gün gerçekten altı saati artık
sızmıştı ve 6 saat uykunun sonucunda
evde yüksek sesle bir televizyon sesiyle
uyandım kalktım ne oluyor diye Çünkü
evde hemen hemen hiç televizyon açılmaz
genelde bütün vakitlerini hele Yaz
ayları İsa dışarıda geçirirler işte
balık o bisiklete binalar Eğer koşarlar
tarımla uğraşırlar vesaire veya Turizm
yapıyorlarsa Norveç fiyortları da çok
fazla sayıda bu kasabalarda Turizm
yapılır yaz aylarında böyle meşgaleleri
var hiç kimsenin televizyonu açmak ya da
kitap okurlar aklına gelmez gerçekten
televizyon sesiyle uyandım ne oldu diye
salona gittiğimde bütün aile televizyon
başında toplanmıştı birlikte burada ne
oluyor
villa ki osla yakınlarında bir adam
geyik tarafından kovalanan mış ve
Kaçarken Düşüp bacağını kırmış bu şey
dedim de dahi bu kadar Nasıl yani dedim
Hani bu kadar mı bütün hikaye Evet bu
kadar
peki dedim Yani bunun nasıl bir haber
değeri varsın için daha inanılmaz değil
videolar ne kadar büyük diyorlar
Gerçekten İki gün boyunca bütün ulusal
televizyonlar bundan bahsetti bütün
gazeteler Bunlar bundan o herkes bunu
konuştu ve ülkeme döndüm manzara şuydu
onu mm bir krizi olmuş
Cumhurbaşkanımız başbakanı Anayasası
fırlatmış Ortalık birbirine girmiş bütün
pariteler bütün dolar projeleri her şey
fırlamış ekonomik kriz başlamış
işyerleri kapanıyor Bir tane adam sinek
tutmuş ve seni gidi öldürmek için sinek
ilacı içmiş bir tane büyük bir tır bir
Bahçeli Evin kapısından girmiş Benim
başka bir arkadaşım ilk defa Araba
kullanırken Polis karakolundan içeri
girmiş vesaire vesaire böyle bir ülkeye
geri döndüm ve sonra dedim ki benim bu
ülkede var olmam hayatta kalmam ve
hayallerimi gerçekleştirmek için kendime
bir yol açmam gerekiyor Mücadele'nin
diyarından tüm dünyaya Selamlar önceki
hoşgeldiniz
Oy
Gelin benim hikayeme
Benim Hikayem Aslında üniversiteye
hazırlanırken başladı Güzel Sanatlar
fakültesinde oyunculuk okumak istiyordum
ve bunun için böyle şeyi S2 den itibaren
hazırlanmaya başladım işte tiyatro
kurslarına gidiyorum belediyenin
kurslarına gidiyorum sahaflardan
kitapları alıyorum devlet memuru bir
ailenin çocuğuydum hatam varsa başlarken
Babam emekli oldu bir ablam var O da o
zaman üniversite yeni bitirmişti ve iş
arıyordu gıda mühendisliği okumuştu
Annem de ev hanımıydı böyle tatlı kendi
yağıyla kavrulan bir aile yerimiz İzmir
şehrimiz İzmir İzmir'de zaten atlar
Fakültesi oyunculuk okuyacağım en büyük
hayalim bu ya gelelim işler beklediğim
gibi gitmedi
oyunculukta sahne sınavım harika geçti
fakat Şan ama ve aynı zamanda da dan
sınavına gireceğim bilmiyordum
Opera sanatçılarından oluşan bir jürinin
önünde anırarak Yıldızların Altında
söyleyince ve bir balerinin önünde dans
etmeye çalışırken yerlerde yuvarlanınca
hayallerim suya düştü ama bunun yanı
sıra bir şey olmuştu yazarlık
sınavlarına dramatik yazarlık
Sınavlarına da kayıt yaptırmıştım ve
hayal gücü sayesinde
Bütün sınavları arka arkaya geçerek
hayatım Bana en büyük hediyesi olan
okuma girdim zaten atlar Dokuz Eylül
Güzel Sanatlar Fakültesi gramatik
yazarlık bölümü bununla bitmedi Çünkü
çalışmam gerekiyordu O üniversite bir de
ne yapabilirim diye araştırmaya başladım
anketörlük ten tutun satış mağazada
satış görevlilerine görevliliğine
vesaire vesaire deliler gibi çalışıyorum
Hatta işte bir arkadaşım o çalışıyor
oradan çıkıyorum işten onun yanına
gidiyorum bardakları yıkıyorum vesaire
işte Barış Yapı kapatıyoruz artesi gün
okula gidiyorum böyle bir döngü başladı
Benim için hayatımdan da çok memnunum
derken 2. sınıfta bir televizyon
kanalının tozlu rafların temizlerken
aşığı görevlisiyim Çünkü bir pazar günü
pazarları da çalışıyordum bir pazar günü
bir ilan gördüm ilanda Tam da gördüğünüz
bu kaplumbağa vardı ve şöyle diyordu
a Su kaplumbağası denizin ağrıyor böyle
bir ilan vardı bir reklam yazarı reklam
Metin yazarı arıyordu bir reklam ajansı
dedim ki o kaplumbağa benim
artist sabah neden o kaplumbağanın ben
olduğumu anlatan bir bir Siri gönder
masa sividan daha çok bir mektup
gönderdim fakat içine de okulda yaptım
birtakım işleri koydum çok kısa çok
yaratıcı bir iş planı hazırladım onlara
sizin için bunları yapabilirim bunları
yaratabilir vesaire tek bir şey atla
tatmıştım Aslı pekte umrumda değildi
mezun birini arıyorlardı yani Okulu
bitmiş Mümkünse 2 yıl tecrübesi olan
fakat O ben değildim ama aradıkları kişi
bendim Onu biliyordum bütün başvurular
bitmişti görüşmeleri yapmışlardı Çünkü
aslında ilan Bir önceki hafta çıkmıştı
Fakat ben gördüm değil ana o zamanlar
gazetelerde iki eklerinde bir tane ilan
koyuyorsunuz Bir tane de size işte
promosyon veriyor Onu da öteki hafta
inanıyor halbuki bu geçen haftanın ilanı
ve ben aynı Günün Akşamı bir telefon
aldım mail attım Bir daha doğrusu
dosyamı bıraktım ajansın Ajans
başkanından BİM'de Görüşmek istiyorlar
da beş gün sonra işe başlamıştım hem
okula gidiyordum diğer İşlerin hepsini
bıraktım o okuldan koşturarak ajansa
gidiyordum ve biliyordum ki Ben ne
yaparsam yapayım Kendime bütün Kapılar
kapalı olsa yeni bir yol açabileceğim
Onu ilk defa o zaman fark ettim
ay yıllar içinde bir sürü şey yaptım Bir
yandan çalıştım bir an okula devam ettim
Okulumuz adı tabi kazandığım paralarla
en büyük şansım ailenin ailemin yanında
yaşamakta aileden ailesinden ayrı
yaşayan öğrenci ne kadar zorluk
çektiğini Biliyorum ve farkındayım benim
en büyük şansım buydu ta ki okul bitene
kadar Okul bitince böyle daha önce
muayenehane olan 45 metrekare küçücük
bir eve taşındım sadece Kendi Ayakları
üzerinde durabilmek için
reklam ezale yaptım reklam Metin
yazarlığı yaptım arkasına kreatif
direktör oldum ve en sonunda dergilere
yazmaya başladım bir blog ödülleri
yarışmasında İkinci oldum fotoğraf ders
aldım fotoğraf eğitimi aldım ikinci el
bir fotoğraf makinesi aldım Bu da çok
hızlı hızlı geçiyorum Çünkü zaman içinde
Yıllar İçinde çok fazla şey yaptığımı
geriye dönüp baktığımda görüyorum ama
sadece şunu söyleyeceğim hep kendime
yatırım yaptım ben nasıl daha iyi
fotoğraf çekebilirim nasıl daha iyi yazı
yazabilirim geldim nasıl daha
geliştirebilirim ve reklamcılıkla ilgili
nasıl bir eğitim alabilir vesaire
vesaire
2014 yılına geldiğimizde
artık çok dünyaca ünlü bir Seyehat
dergisinde yazıları yayınlanmaya
başlamıştı aynı zamanda Türkiye'deki
daha ilerde yazı yazmaya başlamıştım ve
bütün bunları da işten arta kalan gece
12'ye kadar çalışıyorduk de işten arta
kalan zamanlarında yapıyoruz 2014
yılında
direk tane aldım
şirketinden ve bana diyorlardı ki diğer
bütün işleri bırakıp sen devam et ya da
yollarımızı ayıralım bir karar vermem
gerekiyordu hiçbir şey kolay değildi
ailemden ayrı yaşıyordum ailemi bile
durumu Zaten belliydi buradan gelen
düzenli ve sürekli bir kazancım var de
çok olmasada beni geç indirebilecek bir
kazançlı ve kendi yağıyla kendi
arkadaşlarıyla kendi ortamında gayet
mutlu yaşayan bir insanım ve bir karar
vermem gerekiyordu ve ben özgürlüğü
seçtim çok zor bir karardı Çünkü ne
olacağı mı Ne yapabileceğimi Neler
yapabileceğimi bir nasıl bir
potansiyelim olduğunu henüz bilmiyordum
Bir yere bağlı çalışırken bir kurumun
çatısı altında çalışırken Evet şartlar
sizi çok zorlayabilir
insanlar sizi çok zorlayabilir Bununla
ilgili mutsuz olduğunu zamanlar olabilir
veya çok mutlu olduğum zamanlar olabilir
ama kendi kanatlarınız da uçmak her
zaman risk bu almanız gerektir ve
başarılı ya da başarı dizi Siz
olacağınızın garantisini vermez bu
tamamen bir seçimdir ve bazen
zorunlu hale gelir tıpkı ben de olduğu
gibi Orada kalmayı seçebilirim hala
orada çalışıyor olabilirdim ve oradan
emekli olabilirim yakın bir tarihte ve
iki beslenme ve 2 10 sene sonra
Ama şu an buradayım Bir size bu
konuşmayı yapıyorum Ve bunu Aslında
hayatımda ilk Kırılma Noktası olan o
işten çıkarılmaya başlayayım ve ben
işten ayrılmak istediğimi söyledim ama
çok sevdiğim bir
patronun vardı dedi ki Tamam ben sana
tazminatı ödeyeceğim yedi yıldır burada
kritik direkt olarak gece gündüz
çalışıyorsun ama bir seçim yaptın ve ben
o tazminatı alıp iki tane şey yaptım Bir
tanesi bundan sonraki Hayatım devam
ettirebilmek için kendimi bir bilgisayar
almam gerekiyordu Çünkü şirketin
bilgisayarını q o
Üstelik tasarım yapabileceğim bir
bilgisayar almam gerekiyordu ne ne
olduğunu tahmin edersiniz Arkasından da
kalan parayla da iki Cabir bilgisayar
aldım kalan parayla da İtalya'ya gittim
çünkü en büyük hayalim de garlarda
yattım Koç Surfing yaptığım ailelerin
yanında kaldım ve döndüğümde artık başka
bir insandım Türkiye'ye Çünkü bakış için
değişmişti bu kadar uzun bir seyahat
bana yemek kültürüyle Toprak kültürün
özellikle kırsal alanlarda çok fazla
vakit geçirdim nasıl üretim yapıyorlar
Çiftçiler nasıl yaşıyorlar neden onların
yemekleri sofraları kültürleri bu kadar
dünyada
ün kazanmışken Biz de çok daha değerlisi
olduğu halde biz bunları neden
anlatamıyoruz zaten hep bunlara kafa
yordum tuhaf bir şekilde meğerse Bunlar
benim şuan yaptığım için ön hazırlık
kafasıymış olan inanın sade ya Baksana
yaptım ve en ufak bir fikrim de olmadı
bir dönem geçirdim döndüm 2014 yılda bir
arkadaşımın ofisinde Bir kendime mi O da
tuttum onunla birlikte kirayı paylaşmaya
başladım ve sonra aklıma bir fikir geldi
Instagram yeni yeni Aslında bu kadar
güçlenmeye başlıyordu
Kopenhag'a gitmeyi planlıyordum öyle
hayallerim vardı Bunun için para
biriktirmem gerekiyor bir araştırma
yapmam gerekiyordu ve bir araştırma
yaptığımda bizi kopenhag'ın diye bir
Instagram sayfasından bir Turizm ofisine
ulaştım bir sonrasında dedim ki biz
neden İzmirli tanıtan öyle bir proje
yapmıyoruz ve oturup proje yazdım
arkasından projeyi
yerel yönetimlere ve STK Lara sundum
Herkes bu işe inandı
dünyanın her yerinden
takipçi milyonları bulan bu fotoğraf
sanatçılığı getirdik onlara İzmir
gezdirdim İzmir'i anlattı ve
altı ay içinde 180.000 organik takipçiye
ulaştı hesap 2014'te ve hayatıma böyle
devam ediyorum 2015'te önce bir ev
kazasında babamı Arkasından da kırk gün
yarın Kırkında Beyin kanaması geçiren
üzüntüden annemi kaybettim ve artık
İzmir'de yapacak hiçbir şeyim yoktu Beni
İzmir'e bağlayan hiçbir şey yoktu ve bir
arkadaşım cesaretlendirme siyle bir
gecede İstanbul'a taşınmaya karar verdim
ve gözüm İstanbul'a açtım hiç kolay
olmadı İstanbul'da yaşamak her şey benim
için yabancıydı hafta sonları
telefonlarım çalıyordu yenileme bir yeni
bir çevre ve arkadaşlar yaratanı
oluşturana kadar güçlü Bağlar kurana
kadar gerçekten çok zor dönemler
geçirdim cebimde 1000 lira ile taşındım
İstanbul'a ve tek yine ağacın şuydu hiç
unut o Uçağa binerken çok öyle düşündüm
taşıma masrafları çıktıktan sonra beyaz
eşyaların da ablam almıştı bin lira
kalıyor ve sağ bu bin lira ile ne
yapacaksın Sonra dedim ki bana bu Yolu
açan açta verir işte verir Çünkü bir
arkadaşımın 35 yıllık Apartmanında bir
daire boşalmıştı ve oraya gidiyordu ve
içi gerçekten çok fena durumdaydı ve en
sonunda gittim uçaktan indiğinde bir
mail vardı Bey kutumda bana şöyle
diyordu bugün saat 3'te Maslak'ta şu ilk
saat deste şu derginin editörü için
sizinle görüşmek istiyoruz elimde
valizim L ayağımda sandaletlerin de
gittim
içeri girdim iş görüşmesi yaptım Bir
saat sonra İstanbul'da bir işim var
Dışarı çıktım an ertesi gün her şey o
halde bırakıp evi darmadağın bırakıp
Ankara'ya çekime gittim İstanbul hayatım
böyle başladı birçok
Bu İstanbul'da televizyon programında da
televizyon programına da çıktım seyahat
programı da yaptım işte bir Gazetede
köşe yazmak istiyordum kadın hikayeleri
ile ilgili bana o fırsatı vermediler
bütün şeyler köşeler tutulmuştu ve en
sonunda bu kadın hikayelerini benim gibi
Türkiye'nin dört bir yanından gelen
kadınların İstanbul'daki mücadelesini
anlatan yazıları Instagram'a yazmaya
başladım
hesap giderek büyümeye başladı her gün
yüzlerce binlerce kadın takibi alıyor
yazılar paylaşılıyor bana Mila geliyor
vesaire Ve sonunda anladım ki ben kendim
ecramı yaratıyorum
ve bu mecraya yarattıktan yıllar sonra
da çok güzel bir gazeteden yani Yıllar
yıllar sonra dedim iki yıl sonra da çok
güzel bir gazetenin Genel Yayın
yönetmenim fark etti ve artık orada
yazıyorum bir anda pot kes programı
yapıyorum
Anadolu'yu çiğ ki Anadolu'ya gidip
Karadeniz'e kadar Gürcistan sonuna kadar
Kars ama yine her yere gidip kadın
hikayeleri yazıyor ve kadın hikayeleri
anlatıyorum size sadece şunu söylemek
için buraya çıktım hayatta her zaman
hangi ülkede yaşarsınız için Hele ki
bizim ülkemiz gibi zor bir ülkede
yaşıyorsanız daima kendinize yeni bir
yol açabilirsiniz İşte bu yüzden
buradayım herkese çok teşekkür ediyorum